pour beaucoup de français le dimanche
est le jour des gros dodo des petits
câlins 21% d'entre vous font la grasse
matinée surtout du lit il est fréquent
que les français s'ennuie 33% d'entre
vous affirme ne rien faire dimanche et
une fois décidée à ne plus se tourner
les pouces
il arrive souvent que les français sont
des bâtons de leur cohésion rire grâce à
un fort sens des français sondés mais
les sbires du dimanche l'eau il regarde
en général jacques martin après bien des
écrans jésus et finale où jackman new
york je vais pour essayer de gagner le
temps que d'autres perdent 20 % des
français travaillent une récente
évolution qui a le goût chiffres du
sacrilège pour les 11 % de français qui
disent profiter du dimanche pour se
recueillir
mais le dimanche on s'occupe autant de
fondane que 200 corps et le sang
frigidaire 11% des français
hors transports sont également sous le
regard bienveillant des 30% dimanche
pour jardiner ou bricolons le seul point
commun entre ces français qui sans lui
qui prie ou qui travaillent c'est la
recherche effrénée du bonheur et c'est
réussi puisque 86 % d'entre eux vivent
à